let's talk about Jesus and the gays
because Elton John has come out and said
that Jesus would be down with the gays
that's right
we've got a little video from the
interview but you ever think the church
I mean the church do you think it should
allow its clergy safe-sex clergy to get
married of course and and and and I
don't see why Catholic priests have to
be celibate it's crazy you know these
are old and stupid things and the church
hierarchy might be you know up in arms
about it the traditionalist but times
have changed we live in a different time
in China if Jesus Christ was alive today
I cannot see him as the Christian person
that he was and the great person that he
was saying this could not happen he was
all about love and compassion and
forgiveness and trying to bring people
together and that is what the church
should be about love and compassion and
all that good stuff could that be what
Jesus was really all about Louis I I
would say so yes I would also say I have
to tell you the thing that struck me
most about this story was Elton John
saying he wouldn't have a small wedding
that was like I'm not shocked by you
Jesus comments I was mostly shocked by
him saying that he wanted to have a
quiet small wedding and not like a
hologram of Jesus actually blessing the
ceremony which is what I would expect
from him right that's actually really
funny cuz you know he runs the big Oscar
party here in West Hollywood after the
Oscars and it's huge and over the top
and ridiculous but I just ya know I mean
I I absolutely agree with him though and
I think that there are plenty of
Christians who have the same comments in
the same points about Jesus's teachings
and how they certainly match what we
hear about from the religious right on a
regular basis yeah so John this is your
wheelhouse stuff this is one of your
favorite well you know look I think
Jesus would object to Elton John's
setlist in concert for the last time
what's with the new stuff I like the
Leon Russell out but do I have to wait
three hours to get to your song good God
well of course he's right
I mean he's wrong about one thing that
Jesus was a Christian person Jesus lived
and died a Jew yeah
but he's exactly right about it
homophobia is an insult to God there is
no passage of the Bible say this for the
tea or trolls well yeah there is no
passage of the Bible you can use to
justify any kind of LGBT discrimination
none of y'all follow Leviticus and
Romans isn't about gay people I know all
the verses are very well there's nothing
in
Bible to justify us so he's exactly
right about that he's also right about
the Catholic Church in celibacy the cat
the first pope st. Peter was married and
all the priests and Pope's and bishops
were married for over a thousand years
it wasn't until Pope Innocent the second
and 1139 AD main celibacy the law to
keep priests and Pope's from leaving
land and wealth to their children so
that laws not because sex was bad
not because Christ was a bachelor but
because the church was greedy
which means married priests are
technically the conservative point of
view that's quite fascinating actually
it's all greed basis so dealing the
church in the long term actually kind of
screwed itself with all this crazy sex
stuff and the repression and the gay
stuff that it worked for a while for
many hundreds of years it worked but now
we're getting to the point where that
stuff doesn't fly anymore and it's
actually turning people more against
religion of course it oh it always
backfires I mean look at Italy there was
a country where because of the Catholic
Church being there they had no
contraception they had very few
teachings of any of that and the
abortion the abortion rates skyrocketed
the death from abortion were crazy
because they had no teaching about how
to have proper contraception I mean
these things the more draconian the laws
are the harder it is to kind of have a
normal safe life affects the Teresa
opposed divorce you know and again birth
control not in the Bible this is the
same this rule is the same reason why we
have the laws of Leviticus it's not
about holiness it's about keeping your
tribes numbers up and they're becoming a
third world religion and they're going
into the third world and saying your
poverty is a gift from God you'll get
your reward in heaven you can't be
devout less you're pumping them out and
the more poor people you have who are
superstitious and ignorant to keep
having more babies the more the more
size your flock has and the more you can
fleece said flock and it's back it still
works in the third world it's backfired
big time in the first world yeah so none
of it's biblically supported right not
that they really care what's biblically
supported it's about you see do you
think when Elton John says something
like this does any heart or mind get
changed there because the people that
are on board you you think that actually
affects so somebody that you think is a
believer you think can actually hear
that message
on them to explain why christ would
oppose same-sex marriage when he never
said a thing against gay people and i
could bore you with you know passages
that I think prove that Jesus had a
pro-lgbt attitude the story of the Roman
centurion who's please come to my house
to heal my slave and the Apostles were
so angry but what do we know about the
Romans historically they brought their
teenage boy lovers on the road and the
Greek the word isn't slave it spice for
beloved boy so that explains why the
Apostles were so furious at Jesus that
he and why would a Centurion of the
again I'm taking the story literally
it's yeah that's that's how they want it
why would a Centurion of the Imperial
European occupying army seek out a
homeless local Jewish mystic faith
healer to come into his home to heal a
common slave it explains why the
Apostles were so outraged because Jesus
essentially blessed a gay Union yeah
John's taking the highbrow stuff Jesus
had abs that's proof he was the lowbrow
that was and also yeah let's just do
that more reality television more
fixation on Jesus's ABS yeah Jesus makes
Buddha really insecure he totally does
alright so last thought on this so you
know this new pope has been kind of down
with the gays and he's so sort of it's
still you're getting a lot of repression
but a little bit are you both not at the
same time so but but basically he kind
of has said let's get away from talking
the talk better than any other Pope I'm
waiting for the walk to get walked yeah
I assume yes the same thing I mean I
think that it's easy to kind of be happy
to make these statements to go viral on
Facebook but I don't know if he actually
has I mean he hasn't carried through the
knee of these thoughts in any meaningful
way yeah all right I love the guy and I
hope he gets a really good food taster
yeah hopefully we'll Pope can you can
you like this you can please I saw
Godfather three days I know how this
ends yeah
you
[Music]